in so many senior positions at state a
Treasury in the White House for that
matter over the years it's not a
surprise that your name comes up just
about every other day for some positions
in the Trump administration I can kind
of four or five different positions you
mentioned were most recently the NSA do
you have anything to tell us about that
well those reports about the National
Security Adviser
were incorrect David if they were
correct I wouldn't have the pleasure of
being with you this morning okay so the
nation's loss is our gain I think it's
fair to say so thanks for being here so
let's focus on an important job you had
number two at Treasury because we have
Steve minuchin now confirmed last week
coming in after some delay I talked to
us about what is on his to-do list well
the first thing I'd say about Treasury
David is it is the department in my view
that is going to have the most active
consequential agenda in the near term
the very good news is that broad agenda
is supported by a very professional and
rather small bureaucracy so the ratio of
responsibility to bureaucracy is the
best in government and that is important
because both on the domestic and the
international side Secretary of anujan
faces daunting challenges on the
domestic side I would say the first two
are bank deregulation and tax reform the
outlines of what the administration
would like to do have been laid out but
the details now need to come forward
what can be done by the administration
by executive action what will require a
congressional legislation on the
international side one month from today
secretary minuchin will be leaving for
his first meeting with g20 finance
minister counterparts leading up to that
summit in Germany this summer he'll also
be meeting with his g7 counterparts
that's a very important part of the
international financial system he'll be
playing a key role and that also
Treasury's role in the national security
space has greatly expanded with its
leadership of sanctions programs
particularly against tough countries
like North Korea and Iran so Bob that's
quite an agenda and it's an advantage of
a small bureaucracy in the sense you
could be small and nimble
it's a disadvantage if you don't have
enough people and right now he doesn't
have this is Steve minuchin a lot of
people surrounding the treasure as he
takes his office now that is a concern
David I would say the Trump transition
was ahead of schedule in selecting its
cabinet and they're going through the
very onerous confirmation process now
but the cabinet is just about in place
the concern that I have both the
Treasury and in other departments and
agencies is we have not yet seen the
names of those important sub cabinet
officials deputy secretaries under
secretaries assistant secretaries and
although there are relatively few at
Treasury by comparison to defense in the
state he needs them he needs them
quickly what do we know ambassador
commit about his role specifically
magician's role within kind of the Trump
administration is he going to have the
president's ear how does he fit in with
Wilbur Ross and some of the other
players that might help him in getting
his agenda done because financial
regulation and tax reform both to big
projects both secretary venutian and
secretary designate Ross were among the
first supporters of President Trump they
not only supported him during the
campaign they frequently flew with him
to campaign events were very involved in
substantive preparations I expect each
of them and the departments will be very
very significant players on the broad
economic agenda both domestic and
international they will of course work
closely with other departments and
agencies and importantly with the White
House especially the National Economic
Council if you were advising him what
would you move forward on first would it
be regulation in terms of the financial
industry or would it be tax reform the
first thing that I would suggest is that
he pressed the White House to approve
his slate of sub cabinet officials to
get them into the clearance process and
could have confirmed as quickly as
possible
secondly come with the staff that he has
I would say what can we do on Bank
deregulation on tax reform and by the
way on the international agenda via
secretarial or presidential action let's
first do
what we can do within our own Authority
at the same time please start preparing
for me specific legislative proposals
for changes in our bank regulatory laws
changes in our tax laws and by the way
if we need additional congressional
authority on economic and financial
sanctions let's do that but I would
first say what can we do within our own
authority to pursue the agenda that the
president has laid out but let's not
forget that a lot of it will require
both consultation and in many cases
approval in action by the Congress so
Bob you said the first part is to get
the White House approved those sub
cabinet positions does Steve mentioned
today know who he wants in those
positions and what's holding it up I
don't have a lot of insight information
but I think that both secretary minuchin
and secretary Ross have a clear idea of
the people they would like in those
positions are certainly very short lists
but the presidential appointment process
in all administrations with whom I've
worked is a joint effort between the
White House presidential personnel
office PPO is the acronym and the
departments and agencies and of course
the White House is doing that across the
executive branch and so it does take
some time to get through the screening
the vetting process remember there was a
lot of criticism that there hadn't been
proper screening and vetting and some of
the cabinet officials I think the White
House in the departments are trying to
do it correctly I think the key thing
now is to get to decisions get those
names through the clearance process get
them up to the Senate for review and
confirmation so Bob you mentioned the
NEC the National Economic Council you've
been in the White House what is the role
of Gary Cohen in this how does this work
out with Gary Cohen with Wilbur Ross
with Stephen Newton you have some very
powerful personalities there can they
all get together I certainly think they
can the National Economic Council was a
creation of President Clinton in fact
your next guest or later Dan Furillo
earlier served on the National Economic
Council under President Clinton I think
it was a great creation it put the
emphasis on the economic
financial component particularly of
national security policy as well as the
work they do on the domestic side they
will have to work together and let me be
candid there is attention there's always
a tension between the White House and
the departments and it could be either
the NEC or the NSC National Security
Council what we want to do is to have
attention however that is creative and
productive not personal and destructive
my impression so far is that these
people are going to work in a way that
does have a competitive element to it
but it's going to be a competition of
good ideas that in the end will produce
good results for the American people
that's what I wanted to ask you you say
you know that they do need to work
together Bob but based on you know your
knowledge of these individuals and your
relationships they will they work
together will they want to do that
kind of a common good if you will I
think they will certainly want to do it
and what I know of them and candidly
I know them but not well but they are
the kinds of strong personalities whom
you want people who have driven results
in the past in the private sector they
need to bring those deal-making
results-oriented skills into the
executive branch when I was at the State
Department for example I worked for Jim
Baker he was not only a terrific
Secretary of State he was also George HW
Bush's best friend but we had a strong
secretary defence in Dick Cheney and we
had a national security adviser brent
scowcroft who was the president's
trusted advisor we didn't agree on
everything we had a nice competition but
again it was a competition of ideas
which I believe in that Bush 41 term
turned out some wonderful results not
just for the US but for the world